à
petite visite familiale en milieu de
semaine georges corgis surveille de près
la santé de sa mère qui a subi une
chirurgie cardiaque en pleine pandémie
elle est arrivée à sherbrooke en 2016
peu de temps après son plus jeune fils
étudiant en informatique à l'université
bishop georges le pharmacien diplômé de
la famille lui est arrivé un an plus
tard après avoir fui à l'epp leur ville
natale défigurée par dix ans de guerre
j'aime beaucoup cette vie parce que très
tranquille donc vous ne souhaitez pas
retournée vivre là bas non non non
jamais est-ce qu'on peut confirmer la
danse ici georges corps j'y travaille
depuis quelques années comme
technicienne à la pharmacie d'allonnes
haddad au centre ville de sherbrooke
quand j'ai commencé à travailler je suis
pas capable a dit en bon français sauf
bonjour bonsoir danziger a commencé
après l'élève le travail est le langage
simple avec une vraiment une très très
bonne équipe est comme une famille pour
moi se trouver du travail rapidement
dans son domaine sans même parler la
langue locale
ce n'est pas fréquent c'est une chose
qui s'explique par l'implication de la
famille
haddad ça va être un très bon en
pharmacie mais déjà sa neige de
clientèle c'est lui qui s'occupe de
toutes mes clients est réfugié sans
travailler beaucoup apprécié hamas et
les nantis mon père un gros rôle à faire
avec ça je pense qu'il a voulu redonner
à la communauté
il fait ce incroyablement bien
haley haddad pharmacien à la retraite a
convaincu ses collègues administrateurs
de la petite église orthodoxe syrienne
de sherbrooke de parrainer des
compatriotes syrienne qui fuyaient la
guerre
en 2010 2011 il a commencé et jusqu'à
2000 sykes et 18 on était venus parfois
s'entraîner les québécois ayant que
d'une générosité fantastique non
seulement pour la donation des du linge
des meubles des assiettes d'aider tous
les cas si vous pensez cette église a
été fondée par une première génération
d'immigrants syrie'' eux-mêmes rescapé
d'une autre guerre ou début du siècle
dernier on était seuls pop pour le voile
des appareils de télévision
né dans les journaux on est face à un
peu parce que je pense qu en avant des
thèmes européens et c'est pour ça qu'on
a fait ça son père est arrivé dans la
région de sherbrooke en 1920 deux jeunes
adultes sans le sou il s'est lancé dans
la vente de vêtements
il a réussi à acheter des terrains des
immeubles
tout comme ses fils et ses petits fils
allan le pharmacien et son frère kalil
restaurateurs des entrepreneurs
prospères et accueillant ici c'est des
reconnaissances qu'on a obtenu autant
moins mon père il a commenté aussi de
l'église dans ce temps là on voit ici de
la chambre des communes du canada
l'assemblée nationale du québec ce ces
reconnaissances mérite estrien
c'était pas comme une vie normale où on
voulait pas faire on voulait pas vivre
une vie comme ça moi je veux que ma
petite elle vient à la vie elle sera
elle sera capable de tout faire moi
aussi je veux être capable de tout faire
georges corgis a choisi d'habiter avec
sa petite famille à deux pas de la
pharmacie la petite krystel est né à
sherbrooke
deux ans après l'arrivée au canada de
ses parents réfugiés
[Musique]
après la guerre on est tombé à la
dernière étape donc ici à sherbrooke on
a recommencé de zéro vraiment de là bas
ils font partie des 10 % de cire y est
de confession chrétienne orthodoxe
une bonne partie des familles syriennes
de sherbrooke ont appris le français et
sont restés dans la région
nathalie rêvait déjà du canada et en
particulier du québec dans sa jeunesse
elle a appris le français avant que la
catastrophe de frappe son pays
oui oui bien sûr nathalie et mme may je
passe mon amour c'est mon professeur de
français la première professeur de
français à telle adresse mena le nouveau
défi de la petite famille c'est que
georges obtienne son diplôme de
pharmacien ou québec puisque le scier
n'est pas reconnu il a déjà passé le
premier des trois examens requis en
étudiant les soirs et les week-ends
ensuite ce sera au tour de nathalie de
retourner sur le marché du travail
c'est vraiment un grand changement dans
la vie c'est sûr mais on est pas mal
content c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile je suis pas super mais on va
continuer je vais être un pharmacien
canadien